i
[Música]
y hablamos de salud en directo américa
de france 24 me acompaña el estudio más
romeros sala para hablar de un tema muy
interesante que parece sacado de una
película mar porque un estudio reveló
que los micro plásticos están en nuestra
sangre si es un estudio realizado en
países bajos de la universidad libre de
amsterdam que se publicó recientemente y
esa es la principal conclusión no vamos
a repasar rápidamente esas seis cifras
que mostraba este estudio se recogieron
muestras de sangre y se encontró que en
aproximadamente el 80% de estos muestras
había presencia de micro plásticos sin
embargo importante destacar que fueron
22 las muestras de sangre recogidas y 17
de éstas mostraron presencia de micro
plásticos para entender un poco pues la
magnitud de estas cifras de las que
estamos hablando aproximadamente la
mitad de esas muestras tenían el llamado
plástico o pez que es el uno de los más
comunes que se usan y por ejemplo está
en las fibras de la ropa o en las
botellas de plástico un tercio de las
muestras tenían poliestireno que por
ejemplo se encuentra en esos vasos
blancos desechables o en las loncheras
que son aislantes desechables por eso se
usa
tipo de de implementos y un cuarto de
las muestras tenía polietileno que por
ejemplo es el que se usa en las bolsas
plásticas normales y corrientes dios mío
usted se imaginaba que alguna vez podía
llegar esto de sangre pues la verdad es
que yo creo que era una cuestión de
tiempo darnos cuenta de que sí porque
bueno ahora lo explicaremos un poco más
así es que son entonces estos micro
plásticos que vemos el contexto para
entender mejor yo creo que es importante
empezar por ahí también no no hay una
gran definición consensuada pero por
ejemplo la oficina nacional de la
administración oceánica y atmosférica de
eeuu define que son micro plásticos
todos esos partículas plásticas que son
menores de 55 milímetros de 5 perdón
milímetros de diámetro y pueden ser
primarios es decir que ya llegan al
ambiente en este tamaño por ejemplo con
esas fibras de la ropa que estábamos
hablando o secundarios que provienen del
desgaste de productos plásticos más
grandes como los neumáticos las botellas
esas bolsas de las que estábamos
hablando entonces esto es más o menos lo
que entendemos no partículas pequeñas de
plástico que sabíamos de estos vehículos
plásticos aquí y bueno pues en verdad es
que sí ya sabemos desde hace un tiempo
que nos rodean encontrado en el mar en
el agua embotellada en la vida marina en
lugares muy remotos del planeta hasta
sabíamos también que se encontraban en
nuestro cuerpo que al menos los podíamos
ingerir y atravesar porque se habían
encontrado residuos en las heces tanto
de niños como de personas adultas no y
por último pues también claramente
sabemos que el plástico puede tardar
centenares o miles de años en
descomponerse y que lo producimos en
cantidades ingentes cada año más ya
estamos cerca de los 400 millones de
toneladas anuales que se producen de
plástico ya sea la placenta de una mujer
también se han lanzado este micro
plástico pues mar gracias continúe con
nosotros porque vamos a presentar a
nuestra invitada de lujo que tenemos hoy
en directo américa
[Música]
y nuestra segunda mitad del día es de
lujo como se lo estaba comentando a
nuestra cronista de salud más romeros a
la ella es general es la analista
química es ecotoxicólogo especializada
en contaminación por micro plásticos
además autora esta investigación que
previamente estábamos hablando con más
romeros a la que ya se encontraron estas
partículas en nuestra sangre nuestro
torrente sanguíneo
heather gracias a muy buen día gracias
por estar con nosotros por su tiempo por
estar en este espacio de salud de
directo américa de france 24
es un placer le quiero preguntar cómo se
les ocurrió hacer este estudio cuál fue
la motivación de realizarlo
bueno todos hemos escuchado de la
polución de plásticos en océanos pero
también estaba interesada en bueno en el
océano
vivimos rodeados de plástico todo el
tiempo entonces pensé que posiblemente
era una especie que estaría expuesta a
este tipo de micro plásticos por
supuesto esto jugará quiero aprovechar
también para saludarle agradecer que
está con nosotros y a mí se me ocurre
una duda después de haber revisado el
estudio es que la muestra es
relativamente pequeño imagino hablábamos
de esas 22 muestras de sangre imagino
que eso tiene algún motivo de esperarían
poder hacerlo también con una muestra
más amplia de personas
y por supuesto el gran desafío fue
entender cómo medir esto y luego
queríamos demostrar el principio con un
número bajo de personas
pero para hacer más estadística y
entender la exposición
para la población general hay estudios
en curso
para evaluarlo en mayores número de
personas ustedes a lo correcto tenemos
que evaluarlo con más personas recoger
más datos
doctora heather también le quiero
preguntar entonces cómo nos afecta a
tener a nosotros estos micro plásticos
en nuestra sangre en nuestro organismo y
cuáles son las consecuencias que tendría
para nuestra salud a mediano y a largo
plazo
bueno este estudio se enfoca más en la
exposición pero a la vez lo que sucede
es que los estudios pasan por la
toxicología lo que consideramos
ciertamente ahora es que vale la pena
seguir observando los efectos en la
salud
creo que vamos a descubrir mucho más
sobre los impactos en nuestro sistema
inmune porque las pequeñas partículas
también es de evolución aérea puede
impactar en nuestros sistemas claro
sobre todo es importante primero saber
que esos micro plásticos están ahí para
luego ir construyendo más conocimiento
científico alrededor de los efectos no
de hecho quería ir hacia atrás un poco
sabíamos por ejemplo que ingerimos estos
micro plásticos ahí hay algo más de
conocimiento sobre cómo nos ha afectado
en el sistema digestivo que podemos
saber de eso que nos puede contar
bueno una de las cosas
un micro básico debe ser para estar
absorbido por el cuerpo es que debe ser
muy pequeño
[Música]
los mayores casos de plásticos que vemos
en los ríos y en los mares humanos
tienen que ser muy pequeños para poder
ingresar a nuestro interior entonces
este fondo es q viento importante porque
hemos visto por primera vez que estas
partículas pequeñísimas existen al
interior de nuestros cuerpos y eso nos
hace pensar
y reconsiderar el uso de esos básicos
doctora heather también le quiero
preguntar si ya se encontraron en
nuestra sangre en este torrente
sanguíneo estos plásticos puedan
adherirse a nuestros tejidos y también
las complicaciones que esto podría tener
claro las partículas de plástico están
circulando ahora en nuestro cuerpo
la sangre pasa por todos los órganos del
cuerpo podemos esperar que algunos de
estos plásticos que están en nuestro
torrente sanguíneo estén o sean
depositados en los órganos donde pueden
causar potencialmente inflamaciones y
esa es nuestra mayor preocupación ahora
entender en qué concentraciones en el
torrente sanguíneo podríamos esperar
deposiciones los órganos y algún tipo de
efecto y en la inmunidad y el otro siglo
el auto tica dedo toxicológico claro de
hecho pues quizás podemos no está habido
todavía no podemos saber el alcance
sobre la salud pero sabemos qué tipos de
plásticos son y quizás también usted
como analista química y como
ecotoxicólogo nos puede contar qué
elementos tóxicos o qué componentes
pueden tener esos plásticos de los que
podríamos empezar a preocuparnos no que
sabemos de eso
y bueno cuando uno piensa en plástico
está el polímero y están los aditivos
que están al interior sabemos mucho de
los aditivos hemos estado estudiando los
por mucho tiempo y puede haber
erupciones en los sistemas endocrinos y
también en los neuro toxicológicos ya
sabemos que los plásticos pueden ser
tóxicos para los humanos
ahora estamos interesados no solamente
en estos aditivos
si no es si estas pequeñas piezas de
plástico
pueden mostrar una toxicidad particular
y esto normalmente paso por nuestro
sistema inmune cuáles son los pasos a
seguir entonces doctora para entender
mejor estos efectos de los micro
plásticos o sea hablamos de la
investigación que ustedes se tienen que
hacer y que entonces va a seguir para
entender mejor esos efectos en nuestro
cuerpo
afortunadamente un estudio como éste
también ayuda a mantener este tema
interesante para la ciencia y para el
patrocinio de la ciencia en esos
momentos en europa y en holanda hay
proyectos en curso que están intentando
dilucidar los efectos no solamente a lo
que estamos expuestos sino los efectos
y creo que conocer la exposición nos
hace interesarnos más en los efectos en
las ciencias ambientales en la
toxicología decimos que es la dosis la
que crea el veneno hay cierto umbral que
puede ser seguro
y algunas concentraciones que no serían
seguros pero eso requiere muchos años
para entender para entender que seguro
que no es seguro en términos de las
concentraciones claro pero doctora yo
quería saber si efectivamente tenemos
todos estos años para entender cuando no
dejamos de producir cada vez más
plástico que desde su perspectiva
tenemos contamos con este tiempo para
entender mejor o deberíamos de estar
haciendo algo al respecto desde ya
bueno tenemos el principio de precaución
eso significa que cuando los efectos son
posibles como ves en este caso que
cuando se puede afectar a generaciones
futuras
realmente
deberíamos pensar en entender estas
señales y tratar de reducir algo de
nuestra exposición uno puede hacer esto
de manera individual en el hogar
reduciendo el plástico del uso del
plástico de la cocina o en las telas que
se usan pero también de manera colectiva
promover la visión de un futuro con
menos polución y ver si podemos tomar
pasos colectivos para lograrlas un
futuro menos con menos producción este
estudio doctora heather llamó la
atención alrededor de todo el mundo ya
sabiendo con pruebas después en por lo
menos de estos de estas 22 personas que
17 de ellas contenían micro plásticos en
su sangre evidentemente es un estudio
que se tiene que expandir tiene que
haber más investigación esto por
supuesto acarrea también con más
recursos económicos de donde ustedes van
estos recursos económicos para poder
expandir este estudio no sé si en todo
en todo países bajos en la unión europea
o alrededor del mundo cuentan ustedes
con algún apoyo de algún gobierno para
poder hacerlo ya después de tener esta
muestra inicial
si
tenemos respaldo del consejo de
investigación holandés y de la comisión
europea
este proyecto que acabamos de publicar
fue un proyecto piloto
inicio
inició con el consejo de investigación
holandés de salud estamos muy
agradecidos por eso es porque nos ha
permitido realizar estos descubrimientos
y espero que otros consejos de
investigación alrededor del mundo puedan
impulsar sus propios científicos para
tomar el método que publicamos y
aprender lo que puedan aprender en sus
propios países
queríamos aprovechar también que estaba
aquí con nosotros para preguntarles más
allá de la salud o de los efectos sobre
sobre la salud humana también qué daño
hay sobre el medio ambiente no que
sabemos hacer un poco de recopilación
también de lo que sabemos qué ocurre con
los micro plásticos en el medio ambiente
bueno los micro plásticos en el medio
ambiente así como el interior del cuerpo
están moviéndose están fluyendo en las
corrientes de aire de agua y también
están presentes en nuestra cadena
alimenticia
ya hay estudios bastante antiguos que
hablan de los efectos sobre los animales
que ingieren plástico
especialmente no incluso piezas grandes
de plástico como redes de pesca que se
han perdido que atrapan peces
pero también están las partes minúsculas
que se pueden ver que pueden ver se
puede ver que habría algunos efectos del
sistema inmune de los animales aparte de
los seres humanos doctora g del iarc
éste sigue siendo un sistema que debe
ser explorado en la ciencia una doctora
heather ya para finalizar nuestra
conversación en nuestro programa le
quiero preguntar eran 17 personas de las
22 muestras la que las que tuvieron
estos micro plásticos en la sangre pero
digamos en un futuro haciendo este
estudio un poco macro podíamos a lo
mejor tener idea de esta muestra qué
porcentaje de la población podría tener
micro plásticos en el organismo
si los donantes que evaluamos fueron
parte de la población general
básicamente ellos no contaban con
ninguna exposición particular
ocupacional
pero a medida que nuestro método se hace
mucho más sensible en el futuro a medida
que lo vamos mejorando posiblemente
podremos detectar incluso en niveles
menores y eso significaría que puede
volver plástico en otras personas
realmente nunca diríamos que hay cero
plástico solamente podemos decir que es
hay un nivel inferior el límite que
podemos detectar pues doctora gracias
por su tiempo por acompañarnos esta
mañana en directo américa de france 24
un gran abrazo
estábamos conversando mal entonces con
la doctora generales la analista química
ecotoxicólogo especializada en
contaminación por estos micro plásticos
además por supuesto autor a esta
investigación de la de la cual estábamos
hablando mal así es el rabo la verdad
que ha sido muy entendedor poder hablar
con los propios autores del estudio mar
pues también gracias por acompañarnos
esta mañana ustedes también gracias
contiene que nosotros es mucho más para
ver aquí en directo américa